Kevon Conroy's Batman Mark Hamill's
Joker Bruce Timm as part of the
production team one of the most iconic
Batman Joker stories ever told
written by Alan Moore there's no way
this can go wrong right Batman The
Killing Joke and I know a lot of people
have already got their reviews out on
these and I have made a point of
avoiding other people's reviews although
I did get some of the general vibe and
feeling about the overall project the
thing is the reason I'm kind of late
with this is everyone got their digital
copy and did their reviews I still like
physical media so I had to wait for my
actual copy to show up in the mail I
have now seen it I'm gonna tell you
right now there's gonna be spoilers so
if you're sticking around I'm going to
assume that you either seen the thing or
for whatever reason you don't care about
spoilers so can we all kind of agree at
this point that we need to stop trying
to adapt Allen more stuff because I just
came away with the same feeling from
this that I came away when I watched
Watchmen it's okay and there are parts
that work but it works so much better on
the comic book pages I think the thing
is Alan Moore really tailors his work to
the strengths of comic books and and it
works so well in that medium that when
you transfer it to other mediums like
animation like live-action it just
doesn't work even if you're really true
to the source material in terms of what
you put up there but let's not beat
around the bush elephant the room the
added material with Batgirl well I'm
gonna start by saying that if I look at
it in isolation it's okay it's fine
there's some decent decent action and I
don't love the fact that they put
romantic and sexual tension between
Batgirl and Batman and you know I
shouldn't have been shocked because
Bruce Timm crammed that into the
animated series uh after a while and
nobody liked it then either so I know
why he thought he would give it another
go but ultimately the problem with this
is it adds nothing and actually it's
it's a really weird addition but again
kind of exemplifies what I was talking
about with
I'm not sure this was a good idea to
adapt in the first place or at least to
try and force into a feature length
running time because this crammed in
added stuff this 25 or however long it
is minutes stuck at the front it's
personal completely detachable all this
extra stuff with Barbara with Batgirl it
it doesn't tie in directly doesn't fit
the matically it is very obviously
padding and it makes for a really
jarring gearshift if you don't already
know the story in some way this your
first time seeing it it's gonna start
out here thinking oh I didn't realize
the Killing Joke was a Batgirl story and
then it and then the Joker finally shows
up a half-hour in and Batgirl basically
just gets her seen him getting shot one
scene in the hospital after that no I
well that was so weird they made it like
it was a Batgirl story but it isn't
exactly and I know why they did it
beyond besides the obvious padding for
runtime thing they were trying to fix
what is generally considered to be the
one problem would be Killing Joke
because the caring joke is a seminal
story and it is incredibly hydrating
highly regarded it's generally regarded
as one of the definitive Batman Joker
stories but if there is a weakness in it
it has to do with Batgirl now I
personally will argue that looking at
the story in isolation she has a very
specific function and it is admittedly
not as a character she her function is
to have what happens to her be traumatic
towards Gordon that is the Joker's only
interest in her and since the story so
Joker centric that's the only use the
story has for her now where that becomes
the problem is in the larger context of
the DC Universe and certainly fans of
Batgirl
hate this story and they hate it because
the character that they love gets
reduced to just being a victim and
that's completely legitimate in that
context but the thing is again if you
read The Killing Joke in isolation
without a ton of background knowledge
about Barbara Gordon as Batgirl then it
just it just becomes a well it's a
functional plot thing
I know that because that's how I
experienced The Killing Joke initially I
read that long before I got in the
background now at this point I love
Batgirl so I get why Batgirl fans really
hate this story but it's only with that
added context that it has that wait but
they went and added that context to this
movie when the story works best without
that extra context of what you actually
lose by crippling Barbara Gordon so by
giving her the extra time and padding it
out and giving us more Batgirl they kind
of make the problem worse they're
actually highlighting how reduced this
character is going from a costumed hero
to a victim and actually I think the
fact that they even thought they should
try and do that
really points to maybe this wasn't a
good idea to adapt in the first place
because honestly if you're gonna try and
fix the Batgirl problem in The Killing
Joke it doesn't really work because the
this story is so tight and is
constructed so specifically that you
can't remove that and obviously they
know that they didn't remove it it's
still in there but trying to fix it
that's like trying to fix the fascist
overtones in the Dark Knight Returns or
trying to fix the capitalistic praising
and atlas shrugs like this is just
something that comes with the territory
and if you're not okay with that
you maybe should just be adapting
something else
look I've been hiding obviously I've
been kind of complaining I've been
picking apart ultimately I feel like it
doesn't justify its own existence that
it brings nothing to the table that the
comic book didn't already do and do
better if I'm honest there's nothing
that this animated version does better
and the new things that spring to the
table don't enhance it at all and
there's little things about the designs
that weren't working for me either
because they they tried to
something closer to Bryan Bolin's aren't
from the original and again in the
original Bryan Bolin's art is gorgeous
he does stunning portrait caliber work
in that book and I can appreciate them
wanting to try and recapture that with
the animation but the thing is they
don't they don't have the budget to
really truly recreate that so all they
can do is kind of tweak the more
stripped-down you know cartoonish verses
that they're normally working with but
this happy medium that transfer doesn't
quite work at least I don't think it did
and Batman had an underbite in this and
by the end it was driving me crazy
because he has so many shots where he's
in profiled ah-oh was driving me up the
wall now I actually don't have my copy
of The Killing Joke on hand because I've
loaned it out a little while ago and I
haven't gotten the back yet so I don't
know if Brian Bolland drew him with a
slight under bite but regardless I
looked awful I keep I keep bringing up
negative points and now fortunately
that's where my head goes it's not bad
it's not actually bad I do think it is
very underwhelming though as far as the
reason I actually came to this party I
came here to see Mark Hamill's Joker in
The Killing Joke and I got that and he
does great work and I am happy with that
part of it unfortunately even though
it's the part I was most looking forward
to in that part did not let me down it
doesn't carry the rest of the film
because another thing is the story as it
stands doesn't have a particularly
cinematic climax a kind of massive
climax but it's not really a big
building to moment and the and the movie
tries to make it feel like it is but
it's much more choir fairly subdued
climax that the book has and they try
and amp it up a little and it doesn't
quite take again then like I just keep
coming back to the conclusion that Allen
more stuff is too tailored to what comic
books do well that when you try and
adapt into another medium it's it just
doesn't work as well it doesn't become
flat-out bad because like the ideas are
still good enough that you know you go
oh that's interesting but they're not
communicated nearly as well in fill
as they are in the comic book page so I
guess that's kind of it you know I'm
annoyed with myself because I did
something I almost never do I did a
blind buy on this I actually now own a
copy of it I don't know if I'm ever
gonna want to watch it again I think if
I want my Killing Joke fix I'm gonna
read the book again and now I can
imagine Mark Hamill's delivery as I read
The Joker's lines and pop and honestly
I'll probably get more satisfaction out
of that than actually watching this
thing again so that's my feelings on
Batman The Killing Joke have you seen it
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe follow me on
twitter at council geek check out the
counselor deeps podcast on itunes and
stitcher and as for me I'll be back as
soon as I can get my next fix